So we're sitting here with Urs Hölzle, Senior
Vice President of Infrastructure here at Google. Urs, could
you briefly describe your role here at Google
and why Google has all of these data centers?
>> I am responsible for technical infrastructure at Google
and that's the team that builds all the data
centers, network servers, software systems that runs our internal
cloud and we built that a long time ago
for our own needs. And we have very large
scale applications and so we needed a very capable cloud.
And now we're making that cloud available to everyone
through App Engine, Compute Engine, and our Cloud Platform overall.
>> Urs, so what excites you about Google Cloud Platform and
App Engine in particular, which is the focus of this course?
>> What's great about the Google Cloud Platform
is, is really, one, that we can make our
great internal infrastructure accessible to every developer out there.
And then, in the Cloud Platform, App Engine is
really the, that, that one system that makes it
really easier for you to start very small. And then
scale to a very large user base. So that
if you have a game that suddenly becomes popular,
our back-end and our front-end is going to scale with
you. And you don't really have to change your application
very much. And that's rare to see in infrastructure. Usually
you have to do the hard work up front. Now, with
App Engine, you kind of don't really have to do the
hard work at all because we can do it for you.